le film que tout le monde attend cette
semaine c'est l'étoile de noël
l'histoire d'un petit âne courageux mais
non blague ça sort la semaine prochaine
le film du moment le vrai film du moment
c'est tout nous sépare de thierry klifa
pourquoi pour son histoire sûrement
celle d'une mère qui subit le chantage
d'un petit lashkar de quartier mais
surtout pour son casting qui confronte
catherine deneuve wacken samaras est ce
que vous connaissez kane samaras
non je sais pas c'est un acteur c'est
quoi c'est comme ça marche pas non à un
combat non non non pas du tout messi
n'est que feue la nouvelle superstar du
rap nationals
je connais risques connexes fait oui oui
forcément nekfeu pour les nuls c'est une
casquette deux victoires de la musique
deux albums solo vendu à près d'un
million d'exemplaires
l'avion non dits
on verra bien
[Musique]
et des textes truffés de références
littéraires parmi les zonards qui font
de la zique naturaliste comme ceux-là
rattrapé par le fantastique qui font
péter les plombs jusque dans les
cuisines américaine
en seulement deux ans il est passé de
monsieur personnes à icône de style et
icône de poules trn où il ya peu de
fonds dont tu pleures tu te fous comme
un flingue fini où en êtes vous
aujourd'hui pour son premier film il
donne carrément la réplique à 2,9
l'habitude vraiment de la personne
aussi je mens rien à personne mieux son
nom générique est synonyme de buzz
garanti
pourtant depuis le début de sa carrière
le rappeur entretient le mystère
la preuve alors que la promo fait rage
il esquive presque tous les médias parce
quelqu'un de très secret mais c'est
inhérent sa personnalité alors comme en
excès at il réussi à susciter autant de
désir et quelle est sa démarche pour
l'entretenir chit chat vous explique
comment le beau gosse du rap à 27 ans
est passé d'ado petit clash dans une
cave brûlera plus jamais n'a pas cru
l'âge que j'avais un phénomène
générationnel
retour en 2011 dans la salle obscure de
l'éclipsé un café parisien
c'est ici qu'ont lieu les premiers rap
contenders un fight club version hip hop
à mi chemin entre le stand up l'impro et
le slam va passer un autre bolton ken
samaras alias nick troop sainte
à 21 ans rachète des symptômes à la
toiture est opus est plus reims et
qu'une salade dans un resto de luxe
n'est vrai que c'est un rappeur parmi
tant d'autres en fait au début
sauf que très rapidement on s'est très
vite rendu compte que c'était un peu
l'élu ça c'est un mot qui revient assez
souvent même encore aujourd'hui dans le
milieu du rap
alors après je pense pas grand monde
imaginé que ça allait me donner ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui mais tout le monde
avait quand même le sentiment que on
avait à faire un rapport particulier la
battle film et deviens alors ultra
virale sur internet ménec feu à l'époque
ne se met pas vraiment en avant et c'est
à travers trois collectifs différents
qu'il va s'installer dans le paysage
médiatique
donc il ya eu aussi cette espèce d'effet
de on va essayer justement de surprendre
notre public
voilà et de lui ramener quelque chose de
frais d joue avec les codes de faire des
vidéos marrantes
le succès est immédiat en 2014
une victoire de la musique consacre 1 9
9,5 l'un de ces groupes alors au tna
remercie tous les frérots puis tout
s'accélère pour nec peu le fennec en
verlan juin 2015
le rappeur coupe le cordon et se produit
pour la première fois en solo avec feu
son premier album le premier album de
nez creux c'était un disque a longtemps
été repoussée au final ils arrivent en
précédé d'un clip et je pense que c'est
ça aussi qui a beaucoup joué c'est le
culte de on verra qui est un morceau qui
représente pas trop ce qu'il est capable
de faire sur le plan du rap mais qui est
un morceau au contraire très ouvert dans
lequel il avait invité une ancienne miss
france par exemple et je pense qu'ils
ont bien joué ce moment là dans la
maison de disques ce qu'ils ont réussi à
la rampe pop avant que l'album sorte
et du coup il ya une énorme attente
dedans avec entre autres des références
à kundera ou aux grands auteurs
américains
le rappeur casse les codes je demande à
la poussière comme john pente et jeunes
enfants thé dans le désert je crois dans
chaque roue très vite les projets
s'enchaînent
il participe à la bo de five le film
avec hermine et qu'ils avaient déjà vidé
dans sa série casting y en a marre le
rap c'est mon rythme marion marion nous
je vais année au festival de cannes
cannes cannes est encensé le rappeur
s'exposer devient le chouchou des médias
toujours friand de ce genre de conte de
fées problème certains programmes
exprime le prennent de haut
oui 1 tm il était vraiment en colère
jürgen blaser alors qu'il devrait
embrasser la lumière n'est que je
préfère se couper du monde
il a plus de téléphones portables il est
très difficile à jour de l'iphone
j'imagine que le numéro devait tourner à
la fois dans certaines rédactions et tu
m'aimes le milieu de l'industrie de la
musique et que gouvernement celui-ci
pour lui de rester en vase clos alors
que c'est quelque chose auquel il tient
énormément
puis il remercie sa manageuse désormais
le rappeur organise seule sa carrière
naissante 2016 alors qu'il n'a qu'un
seul album à son actif il rempli bercy
il y aura un avant et un après ce
concert tout le monde arrive en concert
et cetera
et puis à un moment donné il ya un mais
comme un espèce de bugs tout nu sur
scène est un peu surpris la foule et un
peu électrique et d'un coup il annonce
que l'empathie sort son deuxième album x
et donc à la couverture de cyborg
qu'apparaît et là c'est la folie
personne n'était au courant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
généralement tous les disques les fuites
sur internet quelques jours avant et les
feux lui il a réussi à faire coïncider
son gros concert à bercy avec la sortie
de son album c'est la pochette de mon
nouvel album cyborg un album surprise
je pense à des gros moments dans sa
carrière c'est là dessus qu'ils essaient
aussi très impressionnant sur le plan du
marketing et aujourd'hui avec le ciné
n'est que change de monde le deal
accepter de se laisser diriger par le
real thierry klifa dans la camping 15000
hedgefonds ma gueule ou quoi
c'est lui qui est venu le trouver et
qu'il a imposées à la prod
j'ai demandé à le rencontrer c'était à
peu près au moment où il sortait son
premier album solo dont qui avait pas
encore eu toute cette folie médiatique
on était presque un peu dubitatif de se
dire que les finances il savait
absolument pas qui c'était et puis il ya
deux trois jours du tournage on en a
fait un communiqué de presse pour
annoncer le casting est là par contre ça
a été une moment une explosion
ça a été repris par tous comme dit
l'attachée de presse il avait rarement
vu ça surtout que pour son premier rôle
l'apprenti acteur fait face à la plus
grande actrice française catherine
deneuve pas mal elle a juste joué avec
lui
du mieux qu'elle pouvait en l'aidant du
mieux qu'elle le pouvait mais l'a jamais
considéré comme un débutant la
considérer comme un partenaire qui
m'intéressait c'était à la fois de de
confronter une icône comme catherine
deneuve qui est vraiment l'actrice est
la plus connue du cinéma français à une
icône d'aujourd'hui nikon ou de son
époque représente at il de la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui comme comme des clous de
mort il a une gueule quand même un
mystère il a il a quelque chose de dense
et émouvant dans le regard et puis il
quelque chose de très déterminé
en guise de teasing nekfeu publie
quelques photos sur les réseaux sociaux
depuis un an s'est écoulé est en pleine
promo au lieu d' inonder les médias pour
parler du film n'est que je parviens à
nouveau à restreindre son propos il
savait que c'était un peu différent dans
le cinéma que par rapport à sa musique
willy seul maître à bord et comme il est
très impliqué dans ce qu'il fait
il m'a dit m'a dit moi ce qui m'ennuie
c'est de répéter la même chose la même
chose la même chose
seuls quelques médias triés sur le volet
comme clic comment ça vanne et feu les
inrocks et à non pas nous aurons la
chance de s'entretenir avec lui
bon on est content que nec fait aussi
était encore impressionné par un quatre
et neuf ans qui sont pas forcément aussi
proche donc il a fallu les mettre dans
un sentiment de confiance mais c'était
hyper intéressant surtout qu'en plus ils
appartiennent à deux générations
traduction donc il ya deux façons de
voir la société qui peuvent être
complémentaires et d'un autre côté on
exclut aussi n'hésitez pas parfois dire
bah non je fais d'accord avec toi il a
vouvoyé sur l'eau pendant l'interview
mais des noms catherine fait d'accord
avec vous sur ce sujet la banque y avait
un discours assez libre ça c'est écolo
voilà signer que feu at ease autant la
curiosité c'est parce qu'il entretient
sa propre rareté un moyen pour lui d'
imposer ses propres règles mais aussi de
se préserver et à en croire les rumeurs
c'est au japon que le rappeur parvient à
redevenir monsieur tout